Oh
Oh what is going on YouTube now one of
the biggest requests that I've gotten
from you guys is for me to show you guys
my shoe collects the young that's
collection of French for you uneducated
[ __ ] that's right knowledge now I
always thought this was a very odd
request because I don't understand why a
lot of you guys want to see my [ __ ]
shoes laughs but I get it a lot of you
guys out there are sneaker heads and you
guys collect shoes for no [ __ ] reason
but I'm not saying this to you guys like
this isn't me either because I used to
be a sneaker head I used to collect
shoes for no [ __ ] reason I got two
[ __ ] feet I barely wear clothes but I
want to buy $300 shoes and one of the
bigger reasons why I didn't want to show
you guys my sneaker collection is
because my shoe collection is a big part
of my shame and it's a little background
story why I even got into collecting
shoes now back in the day if you guys
remember and of course you still do cuz
he's still relevant Michael Jordan was
like one of my biggest influences on
earth
my name is ball handles I wanted to be
like Mike I wanted to shoot like Mike
and I wanted to jump like Mike but turns
out bowling I'm black but do you guys
have to understand that's how powerful
Dora's branding was when we wore his
shoes we genuinely believed we could
jump and be like Mike I remember when I
got my first pair of Jordans I put that
[ __ ] on my shoes I went to a basketball
court
and I confronted all the black people in
court I said [ __ ] i'ma whup your ass
you know what happened they whooped my
ass ha turns out Jordans uh they just
shoes I don't know it made me feel
accomplished I know sometimes I couldn't
buy groceries but you know [ __ ] it but
let's go through some of the kicks that
I wear on a regular rotation for comfort
BAM Nike Arashi rush but I shoot last
night one of you [ __ ] up and
tell me how to pronounce this [ __ ] cuz I
still don't know Nike Master Roshi runs
now these shoes right here are extremely
affordable and on top of that the
probably the most comfortable shoes I've
ever worn in my life now I'm not sure
whether this is stylish or not but
apparently it's in Paul can put me onto
these and I was like [ __ ]
halle-loo airmax Luna 90s I personally
love Air Max 90 s they're freaking
comfortable as hell
their style that has not gone out of
style yet my friends they're retro but
they're new and I'll
that these was right here waterproof now
I know a lot of you out there don't like
to wear bright colors but you know
here's the thing sometimes you got to
step out of your box and be a bright
little [ __ ] Olympic 7 why do I love
these us because they are comfortable
yes and if you notice the trend right
now it's based on comfort if it doesn't
make my feet sing I don't want it around
me little bit nummies came out there I
don't wanted around man
my bread Elevens now a lot of people say
brother Lemmons are the most comfortable
shoes on earth
you're [ __ ] like you need to be shot
in the dick bread Elevens are not that
comfortable you know that alright the
cushions okay but they don't have like a
flex or a mold to them and they're not
they're just kind of like you know like
a little so yeah out of the rotation
these are probably the most
uncomfortable but they're the most
sentimental and on top of that I think
they look the best now I know two out of
the four shoes that I showed you weren't
even Jordans but that's [ __ ] besides
the point Jonah's aren't the only shoes
on earth and all these little
[ __ ] high peaks talking about
daughter's dance blurred as the doors
they shut the [ __ ] up about half the
time is really not even about the brand
name is about the way it looks and if I
like the way she looks I like the way it
feels
I just might copy it but my New Year's
resolutions for this year is to uh not
buy any shoes
been pretty good of course it's only
been a week into it so